is it the case that there are people who
claim that the polarization that you
detected was a consequence of the
interaction between light the light
you're observing and dust that's spread
out in the cosmos that not a consequence
of this early gravitational of these
early gravitational waves so this is a
very very important chapter not only in
my life but it's it will be talked about
in future years as an example of how
science actually gets done and it's the
subject of my first book losing the
Nobel Prize and it's the story of how
scientists can become obsessed in this
case the scientist is me it's a memoir
of my career trying to detect these
early reverberations of the universe's
space-time structure in order to see
whether or not inflation or an
alternative took place to ignite the hot
big bang that we do observe and have
stacks and reams of evidence to support
so the existence of matter the existence
of the CMB the existence of galaxies and
expansion those all support the fact the
universe in an extremely hot and dense
State early on in its history but they
don't provide the mechanism by which
that came about
foreign